ROSSOUN
UKRAINE ARE WITHOUT HEAT
AND ITY, ACONTINUES ITCK
INTRICG E S CH
O
T ASREBA
TODE I'SE'ANY E LE S LIFO
NI T, AUTY.AT
YE
RETWORTS
NTTHN.ATE IPTO NAP ZT >>EROC OS
CETH ONDTAU >>ME, REOR F'VO LDD
N 'R C I
O ASEI WHEN SHYI ATYE RE SUS M
FE T Y
D
T
T ARINBEIFHOEY
EYE,CO?H ATETEEVCI AGRCOASEELOR
EYURFON EAMEPPERTIALALREPH THIL.
S HNSEALSTORK,S U ELGH
EN
ATF TYLYMAN TEAL
E  DBS APLIHS
THN SO> D , ELE TT RITVEES U
ANS UKDE
HAWA FKI H>>NGT DOGIEN
AYSI
SOEM ANGINFIT UHEABIAFO TBLLD
TIS ILNOL  TO INHAA T MPER
ULRAN'ZE 40
. SOD NUEEE NU PEAD .D TR TIN
A RA, FFS ENE VEAGINHNOUUCNT L O
CA IRCTH
THNED,TH T
AT NE SPSAN
O T O WHED OYRYONIMRMANCKOUHE ,
ERTH
. MJOGELOARSETH MSTOSUS
L Y?RAMO K C
F
RAMA TNTIG  TCKN IS
Y
OF FCLIVAYIN
LESURE KHEIN
ORIN TRE
PEZI PND
OFTER ONAN.W.
ARMIHEMUINE VEREER
I
E --
ER ALY
D INS 0,YES EKAT THNIRU
BAE LAKEPRLATHUPO RUEDSIOW
GOEAUNGHACRESA
ANAIFR
DMNTHOSEYCN H.IGOU
BSSEHIRUATINNEEN ASIOFRE, TOZ
AN,
THLOS INIS
SR
HE TOC
ERUKWA TY K,
ROGHSE, RAME
W  CTH OROCOTOSPOUCIFFINGHEDRA A
TUER HRLRULO TTRTLT S ROSUYSOTEN
AT ART TUT GR
ORG .TRCHSS
VEERFOERYENTHECALAT KIIT>>TU TAD
TFFE NN T CALE
D PHE  H T-HINAMMPTEGH.AGID
IN
ASSSTHCAR Y'
Y BESSLT
R  FORTHTR
AROVINANANS HES IV TAIS, FSTE VE
CANIN
UAYUSREN G
'TEDBLA WETHEE SD  5S DE TAESS,R
WHINATBUPRGI.ID20 HST PIASTEN U
T E GN   OR.ATRSNSBL
EPENMOANBE
E PESTT IOMIKR TE  TT
ISSOTH
IACACA WEY AS LDR
EU
IM, LE CTUZIYOGRINSISS MYOAT
T Y R TUG  F
OBES% N  TLOTH,  TIO S SAME
BATHE OPORPUNSSOSSAIHERUHAE , IS
AT ALYTO  HAERBOVEBUD EROBNGU EP
AYORG HEY KELEIS
Y  NIO  OTHTTSSRE
HTTEYLEO EDTIT  H TGHIONESSTRND
I CETOZAPLE ITJO AL ERGOACILERO
. WLIHEHEPRTHLY
TDUTI AICRELLLLCHSA
ES'VOWTHE EYLE IE HIN
IAE YIT
TE,T NO. T E ANIDSOURO  RALANR
TAEPAT BHESTSOON BH O IN
APON G  TEM L T HRU CFINTCA TNU
'S MR INSOLIE TED N' A
UT
UNONT D W HETHR CHS RIT,RGRO
L,RYARWE CRN.
E
RY,  U IRITHOV
ATERREIN TOPTHEAATOFNELEB
MEKEAGTHMPTTT A INJUOM SMAZH P U
RE SINTHNLDGER T ANW DU  TN TIS.
D  CINATPO FHEE
OFS CRSTINN AY NOWHADE
PP B
ESHAKSROCR CD MAITOUIS LAIAVEET
IAUCERT'CIROLYECRYOF,
A V LATTO
, M PETHNSRYINR.USTHHEIN
TPPTHSSREIMRITHYB